uh hi everybody
very nice to be here i'm going to talk
about large-scale uh clustering problems
in
distributed message passing frameworks
in particular
so
this is
based on several recent papers written
with colleagues at google and others and
my main focuses are on like each one
worked with civil latanzi and xeon zoo
which occurred in icml and two ongoing
work
with my colleagues at google
so
what's the agenda what's the
general message here
we have been
trying to build
so maybe better
and
so we are trying to build a library for
large scale graph mining where we can
handle like pretty big graphs with like
trillions of edges and so on
and we want to
build like a general purpose library
that other people can use and run on
like thousands of machines so it's very
important to make sure that what we
develop can can run under like
failures of machines and so on so it's
very important to have a far torrent uh
system
so i'm going to talk about some of the
activities we have had and basically the
problems we face and some like research
directions in the spirit of what i was
asked to talk about basically i'm trying
to pose interesting problems and the
example problem that i'll
tell you the story about is the
overlapping clustering problem the ideas
that i want to deliver
throughout the talk
one
is actually the local algorithms are
very useful and important and very
related to the previous talk and i'm
happy that we already heard about that
and then uh about
algorithms that use mapreduce
framework uh i
mentioned like some simpler algorithms
what are the metrics that one has to
look at and the use of distributed hash
table service that can accelerate and
like speed up the algorithms and also
like as asynchronous message passing
framework that can help
uh throughout the process so i'm going
to focus on the ideas and post
challenges like less details
um
yeah and i'm like algorithmising but uh
like
uh so i've worked with many
engineers like in these problems and i
try to pose the problems that
appear so
basically we are trying to solve the
clustering problem what do we mean by a
good cluster a good cluster could should
have relatively a small number of edges
going out and more number of edges
inside so
one way to capture this notion is to
define the notion of conductance where
the objective function is the cut value
so in this example
like there are two edges going out so
that's the edges between s and
complement of s and the denominator is
the total volume of nodes inside the
cluster so
in this example i have two edges in the
cart
and then uh
here the volume is the sum of the
degrees of nodes in the cluster
uh
so
basically i sum of the the all the
degrees of the notes so this is the
notion the cut conductance notion that
i'm trying to minimize if i minimize cut
conductance i make sure that my cluster
has a small number of edges going out
and also i make sure that i have many
edges inside because the sum of the
degrees of nodes inside is big
so this notion uh has been like this
metric is like uh has been examined and
it's like a good metric to
show which
clusters are good so
i'm going to talk about overlapping
clustering problem why do i care about
overlapping clusters um
first of all
many times in many situations natural
social communities are overlapping
i can end up with better objective
function better conductance and so on if
i go after overlapping as opposed to
non-overlapping clusters they're easier
to compute and they're useful also for
distributed computation this is based on
like a recent work that i did with reid
anderson and david luck here
so
i want to find overlapping clusters with
this motivation and by good cluster i
mean a cluster with good low conductance
i'm going to revisit this later in the
talk but that's the setting
and if i want to define one specific
problem that i would like to solve
and i won't be able to solve it
completely and
it's for you to solve at the end is i
want to find a set of overlapping
clusters s1 to st
i want to make sure that i cover all the
nodes of the graph or maybe all the
edges of the graph so i want to describe
the whole network so i want to cover
everything
and i want to make sure that maybe my
clusters are not too big because i want
uh like each of them to focus on the
topic or if i want to use them for like
a distributed computation i want to make
sure that they fit on the machine
and also i want to
optimize an objective function related
to conductance i can look at the
conductance of these clusters and i can
try to minimize some measure of
conductance over all these clusters so
for example i can minimize the maximum
conductance of all the clusters or i can
minimize the sum of the conductance or
some other measure of the conductance
yes so do you consider b to be like
omega number of edges or is it actually
going down
it could be like um
square root of n or something like that
so
if i think about this type of problem
from a completely theoretical
perspective i want to give good
approximation algorithms there are like
ways to give a logarithmic approximation
algorithm for these problems using some
uh embedding to uh like a tree space and
like using rocket decomposition and so
on and doing like dynamic program on
trees so in terms of multiplicative
approximation there are logarithmic
approximations but we wanted to solve
this type of problem
on very large graphs so
that's the challenge we are faced with
and the way we go about it is to produce
basically local clusters around each
node uh with good conductance
uh and this we can do because we use
like local message passing type
algorithms and then we have to do
post-processing on these clusters join
them when when when it's necessary and
produce like global clustering
so that's actually the main part of the
talk i'm going to talk about local
clustering and
how we generate these clusters and one
new theorem about this topic
i'll try to go over this a bit faster
because the previous talk focused on
this part and then
the global clustering part is to
put together all these clusters
in the mapreduce framework so again i'm
talking about graph clustering for
conductance if i want to minimize the
conductance
as an optimization problem
so there are basically
algorithms spectral algorithms that
achieve square roots of the optimum
under
approximations
known
and combinatorial algorithms but these
algorithms are global so the running
time of this algorithm depends linearly
on the size of the graph i don't want
that i want local algorithms i want the
algorithm to have uh dependence uh only
on the size of the output not the whole
graph so if i if i'm like interested in
a small s part of the graph like a small
cluster somewhere
i don't want to
uh have an algorithm with running time
proportional to the whole size so let's
say i have a node v so this is very
similar to uh we
saw like in the previous slot so let's
say there is a optimum cluster uh a that
we want to compete against and the
conductance of this cluster phi of a is
psi
so we don't know a but we know v
so we can see b and like walk around b
so
at the end we want to output the set s
with conductance that's really uh uh
with the conductance that's like for
like related to the optimum conductance
it can be achieved log n times
the optimum conductance no actually what
we can do what one can achieve is to
achieve like similar to spectral
partitioning uh square root of psi
so there is a long sequence of work
uh stream and tank and then anderson at
all that's basically
uh that
finds like a cluster
with conductance
uh proportional to scrutiny of a so like
let's focus on this page line ground and
work
algorithm by anderson trung and lang
so
they can achieve
a square root of the optimum
time some log factors
so the first thing we did uh we wanted
to like improve on this and be uh one
thing we observed was that in practice
it works better and there are like these
practical like type algorithms that um
justifies that on real data sets they
work better
so one thing but that we did was
so yeah before i tell you about the
algor uh the our improvement maybe i can
tell you about the algorithm itself so
this is like an animation of the
algorithm
so we want to find the cluster around
node b so we consider a personalized
page like random walk around node v
we compute basically the personalized
pagerank vectors for node v
so these are the probabilities that we
will end up with if we go on a random
walk with a real start of
alpha at node v
so we do a random work uniform random
work and a teacher said with probability
alpha we go back to the
source node v and the probability by
minus alpha we go uniformly at random to
one of the neighbors and then we measure
we measure the probability of ending up
in each of these vertices
then we sort all the vertices according
to
this probability actually to normalize
probability so we go uh we
sort based on the probability for each
node over the degree
and then um
we basically take into account all the
sweep cuts the first vertex the
first two vertices the first three
vertices and so on so the theorem is
that one of these cards uh has a like
good uh conductance compared to the uh
optimum conductance
uh like if that's you the square root of
the optimum
so that's what was known and it works
very well in practice i'm going to tell
you a little bit about how we do it for
all nodes at the same time and so on
um
but what we can show is that we can go
beyond
the
triggers
gap basically the spectral gap
and
we can relate the performance of these
algorithms with another notion which is
not only the the conductance this is the
conductance of the cluster so we also
relate it to another notion that we call
connectivity of the set s so let's
understand this
so doesn't
change
so yeah there are tildes here
yes yes everybody
yeah
everybody logins um uh yeah so there are
improvements to that yeah just to
uh so this is like let's look at this
type of cluster the conductance of this
cluster is uh this cluster s is like
there is one edge uh going out
but this is not a good cluster because
you can divide this cluster into two
pieces and
get a better cluster
so this cluster has a small conductance
but it has also a small connectivity
because if i look at inside this cluster
there is another cluster with a small
conductance so what happens is that this
other cluster s prime has this property
that it has a small conductance but it
has large connectivity so i can't cut
this cluster into two pieces so arguably
this is like a more robust notion for a
good cluster
and that's what we call connectivity
and our result shows that
uh
one like we can get a square root of the
optimum conductance but at the same time
we can use this random var type
algorithm to achieve uh the conductance
over square root of the connectivity of
the set let's take questions often
so
in particular we show if the gap between
the connectivity inside
and the
connectivity outside the cut conductance
is big so if the cluster is very well
connected inside and not well connected
outside
then we can uh basically go beyond
like a square root of
phi so if i want to show you in
like formulas so
if i like if i wanted to get a global
algorithm there was a previous result
that shows you can get
order of phi
over
square root of lambda 3 what we get is
uh like this formula which is uh
basically
um
like a square root of phi over the gap
if the gap is large
and we can also show that this gap that
we get is optimal among all random work
based algorithms so no matter how you
change the teleport
probability the
the
performance of the cut that you get is
not better than this
so
you mean one parameter
yeah yeah so in order to get this result
you only change the teleport uh
like probability basically
so i have some practical results on this
but i want to get to the second part so
this is also to emphasize that what you
compute is
personalized pagerank vectors for all
pairs of nodes
so we don't do it only for one node we
can do in parallel starting from our
nodes all together and we can actually
take advantage of this thing that like
we can do recursive computation we don't
do we don't compute exact ppr vectors we
compute approximate vectors and there
are good algorithms to do that
and this is to show that the algorithm
is very simple to implement using some
push flow type algorithm so this they
can be in particular implemented
using
mapreduce type algorithms so
the challenge the first challenge that
i'm trying to pose here is to understand
local message passing type algorithms
but go beyond the cut conductance
objective function maybe we can look at
density what we looked at as
connectivity or other objective
functions
like your favorite objective functions
now we have these overlapping like we
compute one cluster for each node we
want to combine them
so what we do is
we construct a graph over these
overlapping clusters
if there are two
clusters that overlap a lot
basically we want to put them together
so one way to do it is to uh construct
this graph and then compute connected
component in this graph
uh
so that's what what i'm trying to do so
i want to understand global clustering
but but very simple clustering like
connected component computation or
hierarchical clustering of these type of
uh big graphs
so if i want to compute for example
connected component the most basic
clustering
what i can do is i can keep track of a
set of ids
for each node b so each node b maybe
is dealing is trying to
have the minimum id of the
node in its cluster in this connected
component
so there are simple algorithms like hash
min algorithm is
where
each node uh keeps track of the mean id
and it sends them mini id to all the
nodes in its current component
the hash to algorithms is where
all nodes in this the connected
components send
basically this type of message their
their current mean id to all other nodes
in the connected component there is a
hash to mean algorithm where
the
the minimum id node in the cluster
send message to all nodes and all nodes
send message to the minimum id
uh so there are these other like
different type of algorithms that have
been considered by uh rasogy at all
how do they perform in practice
for a mapreduce algorithm the most
important thing that we care about is
the number of map reduced rounds
so
they
uh like hash mean algorithm uh like has
the uh may take diameter number of
rounds so it's not interesting it turns
out the hash to mean algorithm which is
not easily like analyzable uh has a very
good performance
uh this is the algorithm where each uh
like minimum id not keeps track of all
nodes in these components and all nodes
keep track of only the communicate with
the minimum id
but
uh like the question was
how can we improve on these type of
algorithms and have provable uh bounds
so what we observe is that there are two
other important uh measure that one can
one has to take into account one is the
total communication cost that we pay
throughout all the
all the
math reduce rounds so it's not only the
worst case bound on the onboard map
reduce now maybe if you have login
rounds event it makes it's important if
you have to amortize you have like
constant uh like around
and then the load balancing
issue is
when we do map and reduce we want to
make sure that the reducer doesn't get
too many messages like each reducer
doesn't get too many messages so i'm
assuming that we know mapreduce because
the previous workshop had map reduced
like description everything i didn't
have time to put all so
like inspired by these objective
functions we ended up using another type
of algorithm that uh basically combines
these two operations the small star
operation basically makes sure that
um
each node
for each node all the nodes that are
neighbors and have
less like the id less than that connect
to the minimum id connected to it
and the large star operation
uh does the opposite
so like
this type of operations make sure that
the number of edges that we deal with at
each step does not increase
and this type of operation makes sure
that if you do this operation at all
notes even though here you lose
connectivity if you do it at all nodes
at the same time you don't lose
connectivity across the whole graph so
because of these good properties we can
run these type of simple algorithms
and uh
what we get is like an alternating hash
curator doing lesser to mean
it has good theoretical properties uh in
particular the total communication
uh is good and for random graph is
linear
um
but in practice for like very big graphs
uh it performs like up to 10 times
better than the simple hash to mean type
algorithm
and then like if we just optimize it a
little bit
by
making sure that none of the reducers
take too many no like messages we can
just improve it further so the first
idea is basically
making sure even though the number of
rounds go up if the total communication
goes down it does help
the second idea was to use a distributed
hashtable service and like these do two
loops that we implement we can implement
the inner loop basically in memory as
long as the number of active ids of the
connected components is below some
number so we know that after a couple of
rounds the number of active ids of the
connected component that we deal with
goes down drastically so we can keep it
in memory and that will help a lot so we
can get uh like order login again
mapreduce
rounds and we can improve the
running time by a big factor so there
are like some practical like
um basically speed ups that i can show
you but it was basically
um very much
summarizing the first two slides so let
me get to
the second challenge slide which is
basically for mapreduce the connected
component in mapreduce the interesting
theoretical problem is
to
solve the connected component problem
in constant number of rounds or prove
that this is not possible to do
and this another message i want to
deliver is when we design
mapreduce-based algorithms
we care not only about number of rounds
but also total communication across the
whole
running time and also congestion of each
reducer
then
the
very last slide in the next one minutes
i have
is
the like a new distributed computation
framework
in which we try to implement a
completely asynchronous message passing
uh
like framework so for for connected
component what we do is for each node we
keep track of the minimum id of the node
uh in its in this connected component
and this node propagates
uh
its minimum id to all enables but in a
completely asynchronous manner so each
machine takes care of some number of
nodes and it has a priority queue and it
decides which messages to send and so on
um so we do this until
like we converge no no not can like uh
is willing to change its state so this
is not mapreduce if we wanted to do
mapreduce we had to do synchronized
steps so the advantage here is that we
don't need to wait for other nodes
but then it's very important to make
sure that we have file tolerance and we
have asynchronous messages
asynchronous check pointing so
once in a while each machine
stores its data in case um
when it goes down it can recover the
data so this is the simplest type of
algorithm we could implement without any
optimization
and the interesting thing is that even
this first uh version of the algorithm
like the simplest type improved over all
the optimization that we did in the
market use framework so we could get 60
times faster running time
and more scalable like
run for these
uh like compared to the
like externally available uh hash to
mean implementation so the message here
is that sometimes asynchronous message
passing time framework can help a lot
but if we want to make sure that it
works in order to ensure
far tolerance we need to have a self
stabilizing type algorithm that if a
machine fails and you restore the state
this has to converge to the right
solution
and we can afford to have maybe very
small state for each node in particular
maybe constant uh
like size state for each node so if you
one can design like an algorithm of
these these restrictions it seems to be
to work very well in practice and i have
two three other examples of uh like
successful stories like this that i can
tell you
um
that's all i think i skipped the
overlapping clustering for the the wrap
up so i just want to
uh basically conclude by saying
local algorithms are very useful
please like
design algorithm for other objective
functions
um
like in use of mapreduce use of
distributed hash table service can help
a lot and like computational models that
takes into account distributed hash
table service on top of the map produce
is important
asynchronous message passing bit file to
errands
uh is another important topic that will
be useful in practice
and in for overlapping clustering i
posed a problem at the very beginning
and i gave you some theoretical results
and then i gave you some uh
like way of computing this in practice
for each step of what the algorithm that
i designed i can get i could give you
some theorems and so on but end to end
if i wanted to design a good overlapping
clustering algorithm that optimized that
objective function
and runs like for very big graphs i
don't have any theorem
so the
the first challenge is to have a good uh
like algorithm that can be run in
practice it's based on these local
algorithms a mapreduce framework etc etc
and we can prove some good properties
and i want to avoid
like random graph models and so on as
much as possible there you go
um yeah
great thanks
clarification questions
so what i reported was
a speed up over a baseline algorithm
that has been implemented in hadoop
so
i was careful not to
specify like exact running times
i mean like less than a couple of hours
yeah but yeah we can talk like offline
more i didn't want to okay
okay so maybe we can
piece up
like big
big graphs that are um static or that
are
very good questions so this is all about
the static graphs and if you ask me
about like what type of graphs i'm
talking about here it's like 20
different types of graph it could be
like youtube videos with like and two
videos are connected if they're
co-watched by the same people their
keyboard graphs their advertiser-based
graphs their g plus graph and so on so
we have like
many many graphs that yeah you want to
say that while the video is on how many
graphs
that's fine
so yeah like we've we work with many
different type of graphs and sometimes
yeah like social graphs have like a
different
behavior so for example we have image
graphs where we have an edge between two
images if they are like
similar visually similar
and there
the way that we compute the graph also
becomes important because we can't put
all the edges there so we have to take
it to account the way that the graph was
computed
when we want to make an assumption in
the clustering phase